范氏变化这个词在AI圈子被用的有点试试过载了。
Deep Seagull他放起了V3的MRA架构，Kimi的K2系列，然后G2M5系列依然是采用的MRA架构。
圣诞的这个头肯浪费有种拿着高压水枪浇花的美感。
我们现在不会说是我们能不能做到，而是说我们不知道我们还有哪些需要做的。
欢迎收听晚点聊，我是曼琪。
这是一期非常硬核的节目。
我邀请了两位一线AI聪业者和我一起相借Deep Seagull V4的技术报告。
一位是模型架构背景的刘逸峰，UCLA再度博士。
一位是Inferior背景的赵晨阳，他也加入开源推理框架SG-Lang核心团队成立的商用公司Redix Arc。
如果一句话概括，Deep Seagull V4是继续在R1的测试时扩展方式下，
用一系列组合创新和工程优化，让百万上下文从理论进入了实用性阶段。
下面我们正式进入节目吧。
哈喽哈喽，我是刘逸峰，目前是UCLA的计券机博士生，
之前在约战面和字节C的参与过基础模型研发。
我主要研究方向是大研模型的预训年，
包括优化器和模型架构，也有后训练研究经历。
目前我一方面在开发新的大远模型训练算法，
另一方面也在尝试利用目前工业级别的模型的力量，
参与组里面A级的相关的项目开发。
哈喽大家好，我和逸峰是本科加博士同学，
我姓赵，叫赵盛洋，我在美国硅谷这边加招Redix Arc的公司担任于工程师，
然后在SCLang这个开源推理架构和生态项目里面做开发。
我们这个项目大概部署在全球可能有超过40万张级皮肤上做一个生产级别的推理，
就算是这一代开源引擎当中规模很大一个，
我自己先前做强化学习系统很多，
为了亲眼见证的DeepSigRE在LMRL领域带来的巨大影响力，
可以说某种意义上让这个领域得到了前所未有的重视。
上一周DeepSig新代的模型V4发版，
这个也是我们今天要讨论的重点内容，
我们团队做了相当多的工程优化，
成功在DeepSigRE的V4发布的当天，
就把推理和强化学习两条电路都跑通了。
这个待会儿聊到一帕的部分我会展开讲一下，
然后今天的播客会由我和逸峰同学一块来分享。
因为正好逸峰的背景和之前的经验是比较偏算法和架构这块的，
然后陈阳是比较偏infer这块的，
这两方面V4都会有一些改进核心的东西，
两位的视角非常互补，
正式来聊V4的进展之前有几个我比较关心的问题，
一个是V4发布之后，
你们作为一线的这种AI从业者，
你们自己上手使用的体验是怎样的？
作为用户使用端的角度，
我也在ARENA AI上面就相当于是。
把DeepSig V4和其他模型进行对比。
我感觉的话，无论是像是推理，
像是代码编写，
还是说他让我follow一个agent的指引执行，
都要比V3要好得多，尤其是他幻觉来比V3要少得多，
能力上我觉得跟V3加还是比较接近的，
当然在代码层面，
扩的还是比其他模型要好得多，
体感上我觉得跟像Kimi K2.6这些开源模型还是比较接近的。
你说和Kimi最近发的模型的感觉是接近的，
你就可以说中国这些第一梯队的开源模型，
用起来体感都差不了太多。
对，但是呢代码方面，
还是跟国外的预算价来说，
它会有一定的差距。
诚杨你可以说说，就是你用V4的感受，
因为这次就是你在的SGLAM的创业团队Redix Arc，
你们也是做了Daily Infrared的适配，
就做这个适配的过程中间，
你有什么比较有意思的发现吗？
这个很好玩，就是从工程角度，
大概从DeepSigV3开始，
我们有一个戏程，
说DeepSig每年的发布都会为开源社区的研究和infra，
基本上是殉命一年，
会助一个非常非常强大的活力。
比如去年DeepSig提出这些largp等等这些价格，
我们可能前年后后扎扎实实的做了有一年的时间，
才能把这些细节都在开源领域实现一口。
然后呢今年我预感也不会例外，
因为今年他们这个报告上的infra细节非常的扎实，
DeepSigV4依旧是infra巨金嘛，
这次的变化价格也是非常大，
就是从DeepSigV2到DeepSigV3,。
我们觉得这个infra的变化比较渐近，
在整体上是把MLA和DeepSigMoe这两套价格给scale off了，
然后到了这个DeepSigV4，
注意力本身又有新的巨大改变，
这个SWA搭配着双压缩策略，
其实也难度非常之大，
我们在视频的这个过程当中，
也得为我们先前有的这个钱费缓存，
还有投机采样的这些方法，
做一些非常多的优化，
这个最终我们拿到的效果也是很不错的，
在各家评测上水里先地位。
因为正好叶峰你这几天也去参加这个ICLR嘛，
然后就很多研究员也聚在一起，
又赶上V4发布，
就是在这个会场大家有些什么讨论吗？
刚好就是说DeepSig在那个会议期间发布了，
然后大家讨论比较感兴，
一个点是DeepSig，
他放弃了V3的MRA架构，
之前的话DeepSig提出了MRA架构，
然后Kimi的K2系列，
然后G2M5系列之类的前云开幕型，
依然是采用的MRA架构，
今年的ICLR会场上有一些，
就基于MRA架构的改进或者雕花啥的，
比如想并行的MRA之类的这些改进，
然后大家就会讨论，
这些继续在MRA的饭市上，
进行生蛙或者雕花的研究到底还有没有意义，
另一方面也在思考，
未来模型架构还有什么值得改进的方向，
因为就是相当于是，
像几个月之前大家都认为，
就是说现在比较先进的开幕型都会，
就像是它的模型架构都逐渐收敛了，
比如说都收敛到MRA，
然后在MRA技术之上再进行一些小的改进，
那Deep Seek,。
它就像是它又放弃了MRA架构，
回到了传统的MQ，
那个像MQA架构，
就像是说明那个模型架构本身，
它其实还是有非常大的改进空间的。
MLA就是V2的时候他们提的，
如果这个要解释一下的话，
就是MLA和MQA的这个简单的区别是什么？
MQA就像是跟其实跟最原始的那个Multi-Head Tension，
其实差不多的，
然后MRA就跟之前的价格完全不一样，
它是将那个KV进行抵制压缩，
这样的话就是我只需要存储，
就是比较压缩过后的那个KV，
然后在info的时候再把它scale上去，
这样的话就像是能够接上KVcash。
所以就是在比较核心的注意力机制这一块，
V4相比于V3，
它又有一个表达的改进。
对，V4相比于V3的话，
就像当然是它引进了就是tokenwise的这样一些改进，
这样一个非常大尺度的压缩。
我猜测的话可能是由于那个就是底层实现的原因，
就是说是那个如果把这些压缩合并到MRA上，
那可能实验起来就相当复杂了，
可能就是因为这一点，
涉及了MRA这种比较复杂的几个。
这次其实这个技术报告里有一个消失的东西，
就是训练成本，
我是只相比于V3，
因为V3的时候是直接提了说，
最后一次的训练成本是557万美元。
这次其实报告里面，
包括他们自己的官方的博客里都没有，
特别明确的去讲这个数字，
两位怎么看这个变化呀。
我觉得首先这个做一个严谨的成熟公司，
这个Deepseq内部对成本的核算，
一定是算得非常清楚。
我觉得他们不选择主动公开本身是一个信号，
就是他们不再是一个需要靠成本趋势来定义自己的团队，
转而希望用模型本身的能力说一声，
来代表他们发生吧。
最终模型的最后那一次训练成本，
只是所有成本的冰山一角，
就当时候的训练成本写的557万美元，
它应该是最后一次成本，
但是它有大量的前沿技术探索呀，
然后包括像对比验证的实验成本，
然后包括人力和数据成本，
这些才是最终成本的主要部分。
因此我觉得在公布成本的意义其实不算特别大。
研发成本肯定是最后一次训练成本的几十倍吧。
你们怎么看V4它是没有上多摩泰的能力的？
我认为DFC的可能一方面，
它更专注于文本处理的能力，
毕竟如果一个模型它想要处理多种能力的话，
还是难度比较大的。
另一方面对于像国产模型适配呀，
国产前卡适配呀，
包括本身它的结构已经很复杂了。
如果说再融入多摩泰的这样一个结构来说，
就是写音法其实很难写。
你为什么V4训练了这么长时间？
而且它确实也是delay了自己的预期的。
因为大概在春节的时候，
他们本来有计划想争取在春节的手法。
后来差不多，
应该算是晚了两个多月吧。
这个具体的发布计划我们外界是很难知晓的，
然后我可以从音法角度去做一些推测。
这个DeepSync一丝心引入了四个互相偶和的新feature，
恨活GD，然后MHC。
迷惘作为一个新的用法系还有FP4训练。
这个像我之前提到过，
任何一个功能的单独上限，
都是需要一个极大规模的debug的。
四个级上，
这就是一个组合爆炸问题，
然后特别是迷惘在如此大规模MOE上的稳定性，
然后把FP4做这个forward-backward的生产级别，
生产级别的这个稳定，
这在公开层面都是极为前沿的尝试。
我还是一直非常喜欢DeepSync，
然后他们在发的时候引用了一句话，
叫帅道而行，端然正极，
这个非常有意思。
我前面就读道德经，
道德经里面有一句话，
我觉得可以用来讲讲他们这个状态，
我觉得叫做为而不适，功成福之，
创造万物却不占为己有，
然后工业有成却不会自我夸药，
他们一直都是一个非常值得学习的团队。
我补充一点，
这次DeepSync的一个亮点是，
它原生支持国产芯片，
在DeepSync之前的研究，
其实很少提到的，
没有可能是因为国产芯片底层蒜子，
或者接口量比较大，
很多时候就需要从零开始编写，
如果他们之前尝试过这样一个编写的话，
可能也会进一步增加研发时间。
其实我看这个报告原文，
它只有一个地方提到了国产芯片，
就是在Infra讲病情医批方案的时候，
他提到了说，
我们在华为深屯上做了技术验证，
这个就是你说的原生支持国产芯片，
这个是做推理，对吧？
是的,
顺列是否用了？
其实不知道，
就是外界有很多推测而已。
对，就是它并没有洗，
外界推测，
大部分还是推测，
它还是用的英伟达的芯片。
我补充说一下，
就是刚才陈阳提到，
晒到而行，
端然正极这句话，
然后他们引用的是尋子，
非是二子，
在博客里面还写了前面两句话，
是说，不要余欲不孔于棒，
不要去，
就听那个追捧，
你也不要去恐惧，
大家对你的质疑，
这可能确实是，
我觉得从去年下半年，
大家一直期待它发，
然后到现在真的发中间一段时间，
这个团队会面临的一些内外压力。
对,
这个高中的时候，
小二有嘛，
都讲这个，
举生育，
它却是非主要不佳局，
这是非常极高的经济。
我可能补充就是，
在那个Deep Seeker的。
做的支卸名单里面，
我们可以看到，
就是说，
它的离职人员，
其实不是特别多，
对,
可能就是百分之五，
这样一个比例，
就相比于，
就是其他公司，
这样一个流动率来说，
就是Deep Seeker,。
它的流动率是相当低的，
我认为，
不要余欲，
不仅仅是整个公司，
它的一个，
那个,
相当于一个信仰之一，
那个公司研发人员，
他们自己，
就是也是不要余欲，
就是专心做好自己的事情。
我觉得R1的时候，
它有一个非常大的舆论反响，
因为,
可能它有一个很好表达的，
一个变化，
就是它，
用开源的方式，
验证了，
当时的一种新的饭式，
就是测试时的扩展，
也就是，
24年9月的时候，
就OpenFa,。
O1的时候，
大家看到的，
这样一种新的饭式，
是不是可以说，
其实,
V4,
从顺面的，
整个这种大的思路上，
它不是一个饭式的变化，
它更多是你刚才说的，
就是我很多，
这种,
工程的创新，
然后组合在一起，
又能给它完成的，
很好的，
这样的一个进展。
我觉得饭式变化，
这个词在AI圈子，
被用的，
有点蓄势过载了，
就是饭式，
这个东西，
你一定成一种，
十年一遇，
甚至更加吸收，
比如说，
这是什么牛顿，
爱因斯坦这种人，
可以称之下，
有科学饭式对吧，
然后回到AI上，
我们觉得可能是，
transformers,。
Fourth Constitutional AI,。
然后Test Time Scaling,。
这些算是饭式，
可以想象，
这个RE在当年，
一年前，
RE的饭式的意义，
就是这个，
它在开议室，
走通了Lunch Scale的这个reasoning,。
然后V4自己也非常坦诚地承认，
说其实也是follow的，
RE开创的饭式，
然后并且V4的这个定位，
也算是在饭式下面，
解决了一些更艰难的问题，
所以呢，
回过头来，
我觉得，
每隔半年，
AI找个新的饭式，
只能说是AI的发展，
远远不成熟，
我更想要讨论一个问题，
就是说，
我们沿着现在这个，
让饭式继续优化吧，
我们还有多少的空间可以做，
我们还有什么新的应用，
可能会诞生，
然后我们做这一切，
是因为它的上限在哪，
我的判断就是说，
这个有非常非常大的空间可以做，
而且每一步都会很艰难，
像是V4这种，
系统级别偶和的工程，
我还是觉得，
会是接下一两年的处选地，
我们会想尽很多办法，
把这些所谓的one million token，
拆分成非常多的细散优化，
然后结合起来，
整体能跑，
这件事情它很功诚，
而且商业价值也非常巨大。
我在补书院，
与其,
就是从方法的角度，
去解释这个饭式变化，
不如说，
是饭式变化可以解释成，
就是说，
提出一个新的，
模型能力的领域，
比如说，在像，
之前的常温能力，
像Kimi,
就是像那些，
用常温能力，
包括现在agent能力，
幻觉能力啊，
这些,
我觉得就是，
提出这些新的能力，
这样一个领域，
才是目前大约模型，
需要不断地去做的这些东西，
就我们现在，
不论说，
是我们能不能做到，
而是说，
我们不知道，
我们还有哪些需要做的，
从这一点上来说，
我觉得，
就是V4带过我的，
远远没有像，
R1啊,
甚至像Kimi，
最开始那个模型，
那个提出，
常温,
这种饭式来说，
就是非常大的震撼。
就是说，
要去找，
要解决哪些问题，
要做什么，
不光是能不能做到。
是的,
只要,
提出了，
一个能力的领域，
我觉得就是说，
也就半年到一年的时间，
基本上这个能力，
就会,
被现在的那个，
模型给刷爆。
那你现在有看到，
什么能力，
它现在可能还没有，
那么被关注，
但之后，
可能会很有潜力吗？
比如说，
AI自己的意识，
目前AI还是，
人类的一个工具，
但是呢，
AI是不是，
能够有，
自己的意识，
行为能力，
是怎么样的？
其实我觉得，
一个重要的能力，
是,
减少推理的量。
我的观点，
就是说，
很多东西，
是不需要，
unoverreasoning,。
然后,
这也是我对于，
现在这些模型，
尽管大家对于，
解决One Million Token,。
都非常在乎，
然后,
我是觉得，
One Million Token,。
应该拿去做，
更重要的事情。
所以你关心的是，
其实它现在，
已经在做的一些事，
它其实可以，
用更高的效率做到。
对，就是我认为，
三号,
需要去，
利用上下文。
我觉得现在，
大家对于上下文的，
铺张浪费，
已经被英法给灌坏了。
所以现在，
大家可能觉得，
One Million Token,。
是一个非常自然的事情，
但是我始终认为，
英法固然可以，
支持让One Million Token,。
做得更快，
但是我们可能，
在One Million Token,。
做更多的事情。
对，比如说，
现在可能，
我们去用Cloud Coach，
用OpenCloud,。
可以看看那个，
它吞吐的Token量，
是一个非常恐怖的数量。
那回到Vis，
我们下面，
可以展开来上去，
它的效果，
然后它里面的，
你们刚才提到的，
很多这种，
新的东西，
它是具体怎么来，
起作用的。
我们可以先来，
看一下这个性能啊，
就是因为，
按照惯例，
每次发现的模型，
大家也都会去，
更新一些Bunchmark嘛。
这一次Vis的Bunchmark,。
有什么表现，
你们觉得是，
比较值得关注的吗？
Vis的Bunchmark,。
里面有一段事，
我很喜欢，
就是它们是，
做了一段，
像,
Arena一样的，
双方测试，
然后,
我可以简单体现一下，
就是说，
一个问题的证据型，
我可能就是一个question，
然后你给我一个answer，
然后我可以拿这个answer，
三号去和正确答案，
做比较，
然后,
按照模型规则，
给它一个分数，
这种,
我们叫做offline的，
这个Bunchmark嘛,。
然后还有一个Bunchmark，
我们是做online的，
就是说，
因为语言模型的，
评估非常主观，
然后刚好，
我们可以利用，
从主观来做评估，
那所以我们，
同样发一个问题，
给两个，
你不知道的，
具名模型，
然后A模型，
给个答案，
B模型好，
而且就是，
有的时候，
可能大家用GPT，
会发现GPT，
居然真的会干这个事情，
就是,
它给你同一个问题下，
生成了两个core，
然后让你自己P个A好，
还是B好，
然后这也是一个，
很常见的分数嘛，
我们,
管这个东西叫做，
这个,
Tradable,。
对新机制，
要,
叫做Arena,。
或者叫技绩场，
我们看到，
DeepSeq V4,。
的tech report,。
里面也讲了一下，
他们自己有，
做一个类步的online实验，
就是在公司里面，
你不同的任务，
他们可以自行，
去选择，
用什么样的模型，
来,
玩着他们的任务，
并且给这些模型反馈，
所以最后，
Overall,。
他们complete了，
很多模型，
類似Cloud 4.5,。
4.6,
OpenEye的GPT 5.5,。
等等,
然后坦承的发布了，
说V4的分数，
大概是在，
Opus 4.5左右,。
然后和Opus 4.6，
还有和5.5，
还是有区别，
然后他们有，
9%的工程师说，
不会将V4 Pro，
作为首选模型，
我觉得这是一个，
非常坦承的方法吧，
然后,
这种内部采用的意愿，
我个人认为非常的重要，
就是先前这个晚点，
可能是两篇前的报道也说过，
就是归股顶尖的模型公司，
甚至可能也会用，
其他公司的模型，
来辅助编程，
这是一个非常有趣的角度，
我觉得这个，
还有个非常，
很有意思的问题，
就是说，
这世界上，
只有几少数的公司，
在编程上面，
是有数据飞轮的，
就是,
任何一家公司，
如果想要在coding 上面，
多数领先模型，
都需要建立自己的，
这个编程数据，
数据飞轮嘛，
然后,
被使用，
是有这种数据的，
最佳方式，
这个事情是全球的，
同行,
都需要仔细思考的问题，
就是说，
我从报道当中，
解读出来一些，
哎呦,
我好奇问一下，
陈阳有问题，
首先一个，
解释数据飞轮，
中国主要是以，
开源模型为主，
然后美国是以，
BM模型为主，
开源模型，
就意味着，
就是说，
很多时候，
在自己的机器上，
于是,
模型研发厂上，
它是拿不到这些数据的，
这会不会导致了，
就是中国，
这种开源模型，
拿不到很多，
实际使用的数据？
我觉得不是的，
因为,
首先这些开源模型，
当它上了一个吹炼之后的，
部署成本，
根本不是个人能复杂的，
这个,
就是个人，
是不可能有一台，
去200,
或者像B200，
或者说像，
国内的910B，
将规模的显卡，对吧，
成本实在非常的高，
然后退回来，
就是大多数的，
哪怕这模型开源，
其实也是host在，
这个第三方的，
这些群上，
然后通过API的方式，
大家来调用，
所以,
事实上，
无论如何都是走API，
在第三方有这个trace，
所以,
实实上这些trace，
如果大家愿意，
用开源模型，
肯定会拿到了，
不过,
很遗憾的是，
我,
据我所知，
国内也是，
大量的在用，
用美国的，
这些弊源模型，
OK,
然后,
第二个问题，
就是,
刚也提到了，
大概是在23左右，
然后,
比,
千万3.5max,。
和MIMO,
V2.5,
然后,
包括像GNM5.1，
都要略讯不少，
然后,
包括另一个，
第三方的机构，
就是artificial analysis,。
它的intelligence index,。
DeepSeq V4,。
大概在52左右，
然后,
同样也是，
比MIMO V2.5,。
Kimi K2.6,。
我个人感觉，
选择某款模型，
事实上有一定的，
AI信仰的，
然后,
我愿意，
为了我的信仰，
选择,
这个也是，
会有一个很有趣的分享，
就是,
我一直用Cloud Code，
然后,
有一天，
我们公司这个Cloud，
因为账单的原因，
它被下线了，
然后,
那天,
我去用了Codex，
然后,
我的结论是，
离开了Cloud，
这个世界，
完全没有下雨，
OK,
所以,
我其实也很强的相信，
就是,
这些模型，
已经在，
3号,
我的UseCase,。
很难Differentiate,。
它们出来，
然后,
里面去排一个先后，
其实很难，
但是,
我觉得非常，
可以预见的是，
现在我们国内有，
非常非常多优秀的，
顶尖模型，
其成于智能的最前线，
所以,
你刚才就说，
其实你那天，
从Cloud,
换成Codex,。
你也并没有觉得，
差多少？
是的,
就是说，
一方面，
我觉得这个技术上，
这个技术流动非常快，
然后另一方面，
这个也是，
从商业上来说，
这个竞争，
也是激烈的不可思议，
我真的也在，
个人讨论这个问题，
所以,
在硅谷的话，
Anthorpeak看起来,。
它的势头非常的，
瘦，对吧？
它是有盖过OpenEye的，
这个趋势的，
包括估值上，
包括大家对，
这个产品的讨论上，
就是有一个点，
在于说，
Cloud Code,。
你要一直保持，
现在这种领先的话，
因为它也是一个，
相对封闭的体系嘛，
它官方还是，
和自己的模型，
绑定在一起的，
就是你，
背后要接的是，
Cloud 的模型，
那如果说，
你要一直，
吹保持这个优势的话，
那你就需要，
一直在，
这个产品，
它需要的能力，
比如说，coding，
也包括这种交互，
或者是Agent的框架上，
你一直要是最soda，
你要一直在第一梯队，
但这个事儿，
能不能一直这样持续？
其实GbT 5.5,。
发了之后，
我也是看那些讨论，
就有的人会认为，
5.5 的编程能力，
又上了一个台阶，
我就是有很多朋友，
这么反馈，
包括我认识的，
有一些公司的，
Z Level 这种高管，
他们也在考虑说，
要把下面接的模型，
从Cloud,
有些也要换成GbT，
就突避的，
从公司的角度，
它可能也会，
比较快有变化，
我觉得这个，
我们都可以，
之后再观察，
那回到V4的话，
就刚才提到一些线上，
一方面就是说，
他们可能在一些Arena上，
请看排名，
是落后于，
同期发的一些，
中国其他的模型的，
同时,
从使用上，
其实,
大家也不是，
很明显地感受到，
它这个，
区别,
这是性能，
然后我觉得，
另一个大家比较关心的，
效率,
然后效率上，
也是这次，
大家讨论比较多，
觉得他们的效果，
做得比较好的，
就是相比于V3，
他们的单Token的，
推理的Flops，
是,
只有V3.2的27%，
然后那个KVcash缓存，
占用是，
只有V3.2的10%，
这个效率，
提升的程度，
是一个什么水平啊？
倩阳,
你可以讲讲，
这个可能和Info的关系，
表达,
首先,
DPC和V3的时候，
当时,
DPC团队有说过一件事情，
即便,
杀的,
就是给市场来的，
重众的一刀，
即便到了这种程度上，
他们都仍旧有立刻图，
包括最近DPC又发了，
一次大的降价，
我不确定，
他们现在能不能还是，
取一个，
有Mational Game的一个状态，
但是,
我还是觉得，
这是一件，
非常不可思议的，
工程装，
就你说那篇文章，
是他们，
在二五年，
二月,
搞了一个开源周，
前面五天，
连发了五个，
Info的开源成果，
然后周六的时候，
发了一篇文章，
讲了自己的，
推理的成本，
这个,
我印象不深了，
但是,
我相信，
每股的股民印象有深，
呵呵呵呵，
OK,
回到这个问题上来说，
就是,
他们提到了，
这么几个数字嘛，
这个,
类似于，
Flox,
景湛,
3.2%,
27%,
KVCash,
景湛,
10%,
然后,
这个其实，
有一个，
比较,
重要的问题，
就是说，
我们这个讨论，
是,
如果你的实际测试场景之后，
几千Token,。
那么V4,
相对V3.2的Flox节省，
根本不会这么极致，
然后,
包括很早的时候，
就是,
有一些，
第三方机构，
去评测这个，
DPC的V4的推理速度，
可能拿这个，
8K Token输入,。
4K Token输出的这个状态，
这个其实，
不太能反映出来，
V4的,
一个架构优势了，
所以,
Quick Takeaway,。
就是说，
你的上下温越长，
这个效率，
带来的优势，
然后,
如果你就是几K Token，
这个其实，
没有什么很明显的提升，
不过,
换句话来说，
几K Token,。
到现在，
是一个连System Prompt,。
都打不住的一个状态，
所以,
基本上，
我能感受到，
在大家市场上的这些编程，
或者说，
处理文字工作，
用到的这些Token Lens，
都会有，
比较好的提升，
那,
是不是在Agent上，
它的提干也会很明显，
因为其实Agent，
要处理的上下温，
应该是挺长的，
如果是个多步骤的，
人物的话，
是的,
这个就是说，
现在这些动静，
接近Vivian Token,。
这些Agent,。
会很有收集。
当然,
有一个问题是什么，
它是在，
相同Token数量的情况下，
它的Flops,。
和KVcash降低了，
但是,
其实,
就是有很多用户，
反映,
就是它的Token消耗量，
就解决一个问题的Token消耗量，
比之前要大不少，
如果说，
考虑这一点的话，
其实,
它的整体的，
那个效率提升，
并不是特别明显，
当然,
还是比之前来说，
总和加起来，
还是,
会有一定的效率提升。
你说的这个点，
其实Q到了，
跟,
之前陈阳说的那个点，
就是,
你觉得，
接下来一个要解决的问题，
就是,
我同样的
Token数量,。
我应该解决更多的问题，
而不是说，
把推力一直搞得很长。
那我也想问一下，
就是,
为什么，
它解决同样的问题，
它的,
Token消耗还变多了呀？
首先,
它可能在训练时候，
目标还是倾向于，
就是说，
我,
现在这任务需要多少Token？
然后,
还有的话，
就是说，
是它的一些结构，
比如像Tokenwise的，
注意力压缩，
把它的信息，
压缩的，
就是比较狠，
也有导致，
需要更多Token去，
补足这些，
缺失的信息，
或者一些推力的过程。
我之前在，
小公主发过一篇文章，
我说,
现在的这个Token浪费，
有种,
拿着,
高压水枪，
交花的美感，
这本身是一件，
非常奇怪的事情，
而且,
模型,
忠实的反应，
受到了训练是什么样子的，
可以想见，
就是在它的训练当中，
有,
部分的数据，
肯定是，
解决同一个问题，
比之前长了，
所以导致，
这些在，
进入到了一个非常，
我其实觉得，
这是一个，
不太,
好的loop里面，
让解决一个问题，
所需要的，
Token越来越长。
这个问题，
一直存在，
类似K1.5的，
报告里面有讲过，
它们有一个，
叫做,
长度惩罚，
就是,
会对这个，
解决同一个问题，
用得更长回复的，
回答,
做一个惩罚。
我相信这种技术，
肯定一直都是在用的，
但是,
哪怕有的这种技术，
我们也看到这个东西，
在不可逆的增长，
那所以可能背后，
体现上，
我们一些训练上面，
还是有很多值得，
思考的地方。
接下来，
就是可以聊聊，
你们刚才提到了，
很多这种，
具体的进展，
的一些，
更细节的东西，
它是怎么在一起，
运转的，
以及给，
整个,
业界带来的一些启发，
这个其实，
我们可以，
这是一个，
什么样的进展，
是在,
测试时间这个范氏，
里面,
继续去，
优化它的效率，
后面它就是在讲，
模型架构的设计，
这是第二部分，
然后第三部分，
是infrared,。
然后第四部分，
是预训链的过程，
第五部分，
是后训链和评测。
我们可以先，
说一下，
就是,
V4架构上的，
一些整体的思路是什么？
V4整体上保留的，
DPC给MOE,。
和MTP的,
这个两个主线策略嘛，
这四个产业上，
做的改进是，
比较值得关注的，
注意力上，
混合,
还是说，
更加的混合，
吸收,
然后用了MTC的残差，
然后在优化器上面，
选择shift到迷惘上面，
然后infrared上面，
有两个关键词，
一个是用了台湾，
然后另一个是做了FP4，
然后,
这四个事情，
共同于来说，
它就让，
先前的一个medium上下文，
从一个理论可行，
变成一个成本可接受，
我觉得这次的机会比例，
就是,
这一波模型里面，
可能说明问题了，
V4 Pro的,。
总参数是1.6T吧，
然后他们几乎参数，
反正就50左右，
OK,
49对,
所以这个比例，
大概是3%，
对吧,
就是之前，
Kimi K2.6,。
应该是比这个比例，
稍微高一点，
然后他们应该，
再次往下探了，
这个极限，
这个比例的下降，
其实反映出来，
大家一个很明确的，
工程信念，
这个总参数越大模型的，
总量会越高，
然后,
结果参数越小，
我们的推理成本，
会下降，
MOE的核心价值，
就是把这两个量解有，
然后V4,
又把这种解有，
推到了，
一个更加极端的，
一个位置，
当然,
结果比例，
并不是越低就越好，
这个比例太低，
可能会带来，
负载不均，
训练不充分，
然后路由抖动，
这些问题了，
DPC个V3G的,。
这个blog也讨论过了，
他说这个，
就是,
绕底负载均，
是不是应该被落入到，
这个训练损失里面，
我个人觉得，
他们把3%的激活比例，
能够稳定训练到，
这种程度，
再次认证了，
这个工程的，
极致的问题，
对,
我补充说一下，
就你刚说，
那个激活比例，
比总参数的这个比例，
在V3的时候，
是5.5左右，
然后,
现在同期的这些模型里面，
minimax M2.7,。
是4.3%,
GLM5.1,
是5.3%,
KIMI,
K2.6,
也比较低，
DPC和V4 Pro是最低的，
它就刚刚3%，
3%多一点，
OK,
我觉得，
可能,
听众朋友来，
听这个感觉，
像是在雕花一样，
但是,
我可以说，
这个东西，
它的这个，
难度是随着，
这个数量，
在指数上升的，
可能比如说，
从5%到4%的难度，
是一个样子，
然后从4%到3%，
是另一个，
是圆圆的强，
我并不是说，
其他的团队，
可能做不到这个样子，
但是他们的技术，
选型,
则比较，
稳扎稳打，
反软这些，
并没有对错，
也只是，
我惊叹于这个事情，
还是能够继续往极限走。
我的话就是，
我倒是想用它，
倒数来进行比较，
比如说，
之前的话，
大概是一个，
5比1,
或者说，
10比1,
20比1,
然后现在，
V4已经提高了，
30几,
将近40比1，
这样一个，
习数比，
就是,
这对于，
算法和底层算的开发，
然后,
就是,
它有大量用于的，
这个Expert,。
就需要保证，
各Expert之间，
它训练成则平衡，
以及Token路由的平衡，
这一方面，
就是说，
它需要，
各个专家都能够，
几乎差不多的训练，
另一方面来说，
Infra也要保证，
就是说，
这些路由，
能够非常顺畅地，
抵达各专家，
然后,
再合并起来。
除此之外，
另外一个创新，
就是说，
它在前几层的MOE，
它是用了Hash路由的形式，
或者说，
用一个给，
那个相当于是，
一般的MOE的路由的方式，
来进行Token，
在各专家之间分配，
从算法程度上，
它是避免的，
前几层专家路由，
就高度集中在，
少数几个专家，
这样一个问题。
不仅如此，
就是说，
像MU,
然后包括像混合，
吸收这些，
它其实是，
之前又已经有，
大量实践的，
这样一些那个feature，
然后像MHCR，
然后包括一些，
特定的Infra，
它是,
这次最新纳入实践的那些东西，
但是呢，
就是V4之前，
提出了很多技术，
Ingram是,。
其中少数没有被，
应用到V4模型上的技术之一，
一方面呢，
就是我们自己在实验中，
发现Ingram本身，
对能力的提高非常有限，
就相当于是，
它要增加非常大的参数，
但其实它能力提升，
非常有限，
而且,
Ingram对于Infra来说，
它其实也是比较大的挑战。
你可以稍微解释一下，
那个Ingram,。
这个是，
二五年下半年的时候，
单独发了一个论文，
去讲这个时候，
然后包括MHCR，
也是那个时候单独发了一个论文，
然后MHCR是用到了这个V4里的，
这个Ingram没有用到V4里面，
对,
Ingram是比一般的transformer,。
它相当于是把，
就是两个token，
或者多个token，
就是合起来，
作为一个新的token，
就是进行编码，
然后再输入到对应的成数里面，
就一般的输入input embedding，
它只是真的单token进行，
编码,
但是Ingram,。
是对于连续的几个token，
它会有一个全新的编码，
理论上可以提高，
像大海捞针这种能力，
但是呢，
就是说，
实际上来说，
Ingram,
它的减效果非常有限，
是强调了，
信号加强的这样一个作用，
至少在短期之内，
一般的frontier lab的模型，
应该不会采用这个方案。
那我们可以按照，
就陈阳理说的，
偶和起来，
工程爆炸的这四个点，
我们可以展开说一说，
一个是这个注意力的变化，
它现在是用了一个，
混合了CSA和HCA的，
这样一个新的注意力的机制，
其实我们，
之前2025年，
到现在的好几期节目里，
都专门讨论了，
这个注意力机制的变化，
然后DBC和一直走的，
都是这个，
吸收注意力的改进，
你们可以简单的分享一下，
就这次的改进，
具体是有哪些提升，
包括你们看到的，
就是它背后，
可能是一个什么样的思路，
可能给大家的启发是什么，
一个是说，
他们的注意力是怎么用的，
以及这个吸收注意力嘛，
然后,
肯定有个对等的名词，
叫做这个限性注意力，
这个就是一个，
非常容易掐架的话题了，
这个简单来说，
V4的注意力，
是每一层都在跑一个，
滑动窗口注意力嘛，
我们叫做这个sliding window attention,。
然后还有一个常制注意力，
可能是CSA或者HCA，
这个CSA是一个吸收路线，
然后在序列维度，
会做一个4比1的压缩，
然后再做一个top key的选取，
HCA可能是一个更激进的方法，
做这个128分之一的压缩，
然后保持一个绸密注意力，
然后他们这个，
正合一层选择，
CSA还是HCA,。
是一个预定义的，
因此这个，
同一个上下文，
从不同的层来看，
这个,
有的是吸收线，
有的是绸密层，
然后吸收层，
会来锁定这些关键的token，
然后绸密层，
我个人认为，
它会提供一种，
与其上的概了，
对于工程团队来说，
我们SCLUng在实现这个，
混合方案上面，
其实会有很多的挑战，
我们最后，
把这个复杂问题，
集中需要处理的是，
这个,
前坠缓存的一致性，
我们开发了一套，
缓存架构，
称之为shadow relics,。
然后这套设计，
就是为了应对这个问题，
然后我们做了，
三个抑购的KVCash池，
给这个SWA和C4C128，
都加了压缩状态，
然后,
同时我们还有这个，
绸密在prefile decode,。
这三个阶段都保持同步，
可以听上去，
这些问题的复杂性，
相比v3阶段又上一个台阶，
而且这也，
不是m1a时代需要解决的问题，
之前我可能听到过，
应该也是晚点的播客吧，
当时采访了松林，
然后他讲，
dpsc内部是比较看好稀疏，
而不是线性的，
我是比较认为，
稀疏在工程上面，
是一个更容易控制的方案，
然后和现在这KVCash，
prefilecash的技术设施，
都有比较好的清合性，
然后线性注意力的话，
我目前没有听到，
有非常强大的模型，
就是现在这个规模的方T2模型，
能够验证了这一套工具，
对，我补充一点，
就是我看来的话，
线性注意力，
它是能够很好地，
提高模型推理速度的，
因此它其实被管换应用，
在千万三点五的，
这种中效性的模型当中，
但是呢，
像松林提说，
Gate2.net之类的结构，
它在隐藏状态更新的过程中，
它每一部token的信息，
它都会不断的压缩，
因此在需要长生注意力的任务，
比像推理啊，
比像数学推导这些任务上，
它较于那个，
非线性注意力，
它的上限可能就比较低，
因此在更大的模型，
像DeepSickV4,。
Gate2.net5.1这些模型当中，
目前来说，
还是采用的稀有注意力，
或者说，
SidingWinWindowTension这样一个结构,。
就是一个非常直观的例子，
就是说，
比如说，
第1个token到第1,024个token,。
如果是现行注意力，
它需要压缩1，023次，
对,
但如果是128窗口的SidingWinWindowTension,。
它只需要挑8次，
这两个token就能个几乎无损地进行，
那个信息交流，
对,
所以说，
要充上线的模型，
它肯定是，
比较倾向于，
吸收和滑动注意力的，
然而吸收注意力，
对于训练Infra的性能要求较高，
然后滑动注意力，
实现相对简单，
然后短程注意力能力比较强，
因此我觉得，
在未来一段时间的话，
那个SidingWinWinWindowTension,。
这种注意力的模型，
可能会越来越多，
之前其实Kimi，
有可能有考虑过，
就是在，
接下来的比较大的模型上，
用现行注意力的，
结构,
就是混合了，
现行注意力的结构，
对,
但是,
为什么要用符合，
而不单纯用那个全，
现行呢，
就是因为，
这现行还是有一个，
信息压缩的问题，
就必须得用全注意力，
来进行兜底，
其实上次，
又和杨松林聊，
那一期播客的时候，
刚好是赶上minimax，
他又换成全注意力了，
他之前有一个版本，
就minimax2.0,。
他用的是一个，
他们叫lightning attention,。
就是一种，
混合了，
现行注意力的注意力，
但在2.1,
他又,
改回全注意力了，
我还有点印象，
因为minimax2.0的,。
支持是我做的，
minimaxM1,。
应该是一个，
现行注意力的模型，
但是mr,
二开头的模型，
都是全注意力，
当时,
我还和他们做算法的同事，
有过交流，
就是为什么会take it back，
我们在我们lmcs.org的，
这个blog上面，
也讲够，
我们称之叫the no free，
no free launch,。
这个欢迎大家，
可以去读一读，
当时的这个blog，
然后退回来，
就是说，
我们最近有一个，
新的工作，
叫做high sparse,。
是在clog上面，
支持的一个，
cfcashoffload的一个工作，
展览来说，
我们对吸收注意力，
设计的一套，
特定的cfcash，
卸载策略，
我们能够把，
吸收注意力的cfcash，
预卸到这个host memory上面，
然后在，
常向台湾常计上面，
能够把吞吐量，
做到5倍以上，
然后类似于v4，
这种把成本，
加速到这个，
27%-10%的这种模型，
要在生产环境上，
跑出商业价值，
我个人认为，
我们这个shadowredex，
还有high sparse,。
这一套，
底层给同事推进，
非常非常有，
前景,
然后这也是我们，
谈的一直在做个事情，
那,
接下来可以聊一下，
就是它价格里的，
另外就是，
你说的那四个变化，
另外两个，
一个是mhc，
还有一个是，
在这么大的规模上，
用了myone的优化器，
我们可以先从myone开始聊，
因为这个可能，
业界的实践会比较多，
包括刚才也提到说，
kimi其实也用了，
这个,
优化器的开发者，
就是那个callerjordan,。
他也是因为这个成果，
但是在24年12月，
就被招入了open i，
他本来是一个个人开发者，
今年在好几个场合上，
包括在gdc上，
杨志玲也是一直在讲，
kimi他们对myone的一个优化，
那个版本是叫one light，
这个ePhone你可以先讲讲，
优化器，
它在模型训练里，
本来是起一个什么作用的，
为什么，
现在一个趋势，
就是好像，
大家都用myone比较多了，
就是优化器的话，
就相当于是，
就是,
模型训练，
原理,
就是用剃度下降，
或者类似的方式，
然后让那个，
就是模型逐步，
去向于，
它定义loss，
最小的那些地方嘛，
最开始是，
大家都在用admw，
进行训练，
它这个本质上，
就是说，
融合了动量，
以及,
它的更新量的，
归一化，
的这两个技术，
动量能够，
让那个，
就是它的更新更加smooth，
归一化的是，
让它每一步，
skill是比较统一的，
它就能够进一步的，
稳定训练，
但是呢，
admw,
它是对于每一个元素，
进行的更新，
它不涉及到，
整个矩阵的更新，
迷人的提出，
就是,
为了解决admw，
只针对单个参数，
进行的更新，
相当于是，
它对于二维的参数，
比像线性层，
就是,
本质上是矩阵惩罚，
提出了，
效率更加高的一个优化，
能够捕捉，
就是,
二维参数，
各个元素之间的信息，
以前的那个，
工具的问题是，
它忽略了元素之间的联系，
就会导致有些元素，
就是,
已经讯好了，
那,
就是,
比如同样一个矩阵里面，
有些元素，
可能已经，
讯到收敛了，
但有些元素，
还没讯到收敛，
讯了时间更长，
没有把，
整个矩阵，
看中一个整体，
去进行更优化，
使得,
整个矩阵，
各个元素之间，
它步调一致，
它就优化更快，
但是呢，
在二十四年底的时候，
Color Jordan,。
刚开始提出的时候，
它是对于，
每一个不同的模组，
比如像线性层，
去特意的，
去调它的Nerler Rate，
对于使用者来说，
就是,
不是特别优好，
但到那个，
二五年初的时候，
Kimmie提的Moonlight,。
这样一个优化器，
就是,
感情的Mewen，
使得Mewen,。
它能够，
和Alum W,。
进行结合，
就是,
因为在一位的参数上，
它并不是矩阵，
就是,
Mewen,
它必须要，
继续矩阵进行更新，
而一位参数上，
它没有矩阵这个概念，
于是呢，
就还是用了Alum W，
还是一样的，
但是呢，
Mewen和Alum W的Ner Rate,。
在Kill Jordan,。
提出来的时候，
是并不知道，
它们两个比例的，
而那个Moonlight,。
一个重要的，
那个贡献，
就是说，
把这个比例，
的系数，
基本上给它确定了，
就是0.2,
然后这V4，
就进步，
改进了，
就是0.18,
然后使得，
就是说，
我只需要，
调一个Ner Rate，
就可以使用整个模型，
对，这样的话，
Mewen才从,。
一个理论上的，
创新,
实际上的大规模应用，
嗯,
所以Kimi,
做了Mewen Lite,。
这个改进之后，
可以说，
业界也是广泛的使用了，
是吗?
对，就像，
我全局只需要，
调一个参数就够，
但是呢，
就是比较特别的是，
V4,
它不,
没有使用Mewen Lite，
提数0.2,
它用了更精确的，
0.18,
诶,
陈阳有什么补充吗？
油画器，
需要你们InfoR，
配合做什么吗？
就,
大家从AdmW，
变成不了啊，
推理测，
这是一个不小关心，
推理本来就不涉及到，
这个参数跟新码，
然后在训练测，
这个是已经需要做到的，
然后,
整个,
链条动起来，
会是一个非常庞大的工程，
要从NVIDIA的Megatron,。
或者是Megatron Bridge,。
这一层，
还要改，
然后一层次往下传，
但是我说的是，
针对开源而言，
这是,
对于BWN的这些，
训练已经，
他们的Mewen，
怎么实现，
这个我也不懂，
欢迎这个我倒是，
了解一下，
对,
因为它是，
现在是，
举证层面的，
这样一个优化，
它设计要大量举证惩罚，
如果说，
模型的某个举证比较大，
那它会需要，
设计要大量的，
就是拆分，
它可能会需要，
分布式的训练，
这个是ADMW是没有的，
对,
因为ADMW就是，
每个元素单独更新，
就是元素可以无限拆分，
这个是Mewen的，
特有的这样一个，
音法的问题，
所以在训练的过程中，
它会设计要大量的，
这个拆分啊，
和弼啊，
这些操作，
然后还有一个，
就是说是，
预讯链和后讯链的，
那个优化器，
基本上得保持一致，
对,
就是说，
就是预讯链用ADMW，
后讯链也得用ADMW，
预讯链有Mewen，
后讯链也得用Mewen，
Post Training的,。
它比预讯链的，
结构上更加复杂，
又导致了，
如果说，
后讯链，
它要用Mewen的话，
它可能会，
设计到更多的，
因为它可能，
在一个机器上，
装不下，
现在开源的模型，
就近期更新，
是不是都用上Mewen了？
大部分模型，
应该都改到Mewen，
但是应该，
还是有一部分用的，
ADMW,
前问,
好像没有特别提及，
它的模型的，
优化器是什么？
现在还没有改的是，
因为觉得ADMW，
有它的好处，
还是说，
还没来得及改？
就我认为，
可能大部分，
还是没来得及改吧？
尤其是，
它的Infra,。
其实是很难改的，
如果说，
后讯链，
它没改成功能的话，
就导致了预讯链，
也就只能用ADMW，
先将就讯讯，
那我可以把这个东西，
作为一个判断，
模型团队，
自己的Infra，
能力强弱的，
标志之一吗？
也可以这么说，
这个挺有意思的，
所以你觉得，
基本上就是一个，
确定的趋势了，
可能之后，
就变成行业的主流了，
只不过，
在一个过渡阶段，
有的人用了，
是的,
但是呢，
就是需要注意点是，
即便是用的，
Mewen的模型，
它在像，
像输入的Invading，
和输出Invading，
这种模块来说，
它还是得用ADMW，
其实,
这个可以简单纠正一下，
就刚才一封提到这个，
ADMW,
可能不太需要多签分，
这个东西不一定，
因为,
它跟你的模型，
体量相关，
就是说，
你的模型都上Train了，
不可能在任何一个，
Note是my host,。
下来的，
Mewen和ADMW,。
肯定是要做非常复杂的，
毕竟策略的，
而且,
Mewen只会比ADMW还复杂，
这个,
简单,
可以简单想想，
还有Mewen和ADMW的区别，
就是说，
ADMW是同时会维护这个，
Momentum,。
和Motulin,。
这个什么的，
应该就是，
动量,
和速度两个State嘛，
然后这些，
都是,
我们先前用的，
给ADMW都是Elementwise的算字，
然后,
所以它用来做，
签分贵相对简单一点，
就是你的zero stage怎么签，
你的FSTP,
这东西怎么做，
怎么做partial，
然后你的TP怎么对齐，
相对而言会简单一些，
然后Mewen的话，
它把这个，
二层的Momentum砍掉了，
所以Optimizer stage,。
就是从两倍调造了一倍，
这个肯定能够，
结实相当大量的显存，
不过,
代价就是说，
它在Momentum上面，
跑完一轮，
这个,
牛顿舒尔曼，
迭代之后，
还要做挣招化，
然后,
这就不是一个，
做成了，
相当于以前是，
可能一个一个元素去做peak，
现在已经变成一个，
更为复杂的矩阵计算，
我们叫做一个jim，
所以为了做这个jim，
它是得拿到一个，
完整的二位权重的，
所以说，
如果你之前你的这些参数，
它被切得很碎，
比如说被TP，
或者被FSTP给切碎了，
那么你还得把它，
聚合回来，
再来计算，
所以这里，
涉及到很多分布式的言语，
然后,
这一些讨论，
最终得受的效果就是说，
我们可以看，
在K2里面，
Kimi我印象中，
他们老老实实，
就只在这个，
就是data parallelism这个层面，
去做迷惘的切分，
他们不会去在这个，
张量毕竟上面，
去做切分，
然后,
以及刚才逆风系列，
提到的这个，
Invading Layer Lorm,。
还有BIOS,
这些存其实，
还是走的ADMW，
所以,
Optimizer存,。
现在到了一个，
非常混杂的一个状态，
然后它的调度逻辑，
它的这些，
给State做的trap point,。
还有做的这些，
就是,
就是我们叫做trap point resume，
都有远超以前的，
这个复杂度，
然后迷惘，
可能,
它不是那么一个简单的，
换掉ADMW,
就是,
你可以想象，
我们用了大量的人力，
大量迷反复杂度，
去置换出来了，
一个当量的显存和，
修典效率，
然后,
这笔账值不值得，
取决于每一个团队的，
工程水平，
然后也取决于，
你有多少的显卡，
你训练的模型规模有多大，
但是,
逆风提到一个观点比较对，
就是,
检验一个团队，
工程优化，
上线的，
很好试金识，
这个我非常的认可，
这个,
专业名字，
听见非常的头疼，
但事实上，
那个想见，
当我也报参名的，
说出这么多名词的时候，
这里提到的每一个名词，
都是可能是一个，
Engineering Day的复杂度,。
就是,
否则,
之外一点，
就是,
每一个名词，
都对应着一篇文章，
那这是优化器的这部分，
然后,
关于MHC的话，
就简单来说，
这是一个什么改进，
解决什么问题的？
对,
就是,
MHC是,
之前是基于，
自己的Hybrid Connection,。
这样一个工作，
它是,
扩散的，
成语层之间的，
星期六的宽度，
以前的传说门，
它现在是，
成语层之间，
假设,
就是,
每一层之间，
它只有地位的，
星期六宽度，
而Hybrid Connection的话,。
就是,
我在地位之上，
再加了一个，
Channel Way,。
就是,
现在有Channel乘域地，
这么大一个星期六宽度，
现在就是，
地乘C,
现在都大了C倍，
这样的话，
就能够更好，
让模型的能力，
进一步提升嘛，
对它的星期六，
更大了，
它的模型的，
就是推力，
什么的能力，
就会有，
显弱的提升，
但是呢，
就是,
普速的Hybrid Connection,。
它的数学原理，
就导致了，
它的企图回传，
不太稳定，
训练不太稳定，
所以说，
就是,
之前,
直接提出来过后，
其实,
社区的反向，
不是特别大，
它加入了，
这个,
星红Club的算吧，
就是,
相当于是，
它限制了，
整个星期六的，
Scale是1,。
横朔都是1，
就相当于，
控制了，
就是,
正向和反向传播，
它不至于，
爆炸火消失，
这个改进呢，
我认为，
一方面，
就是,
需要对于，
这个,
前任Hybrid Connection,。
这样的，
那个,
细色分析，
然后,
另一方面呢，
就是说，
它可能是，
在大小，
来发现一些现象，
然后,
从现象去倒退，
我怎么样去解决，
这样一个问题，
所以,
这算DBC,
一个比较独特的，
判断也好，
或者说，
它的什么，
选择也好，
就是,
他们选择去改进这个事，
本身在当时，
可能也不是，
很多人在做，
对,
在现在，
所有的这种，
就是,
到这个规模，
比T大,
左右的这种模型里面，
是不是也只有VC，
用了这个东西，
就这并不算，
MHC带来的，
这个模型，
比如说，那些方面的，
提升,
直观呢，
看法就是，
推力能力，
就相当于，
有了大幅度增长，
就是说，
我不必等着，
那个信息，
从第一层，
慢慢慢慢，
传到最后一层，
而说,
就是,
我的车道变还了，
推力能力，
有大幅的提升，
这个是当时，
DBC在MHC,。
这个单组的论文里面，
他们专门，
是做了，
比如说，
控制辨量的，
这种,
非常精确的比较嘛，
这个,
它的具体，
是不是能力提升，
它只,
去比较它，
一些benchmark,。
另外一个，
我想补充一点，
就是说，
MHC,
它是从，
增加信息的宽度，
去进行，
增加乘用程之间，
信息的互动，
然后,
最近我也注意到，
KIMIT,
就是attention procedure,。
它是像dansnet，
它乘用程之间，
直接就是说，
就是,
跨从,
进行互相连接，
它不需要，
就是,
每一层每一层，
这样连接，
也可以，
直接去影响，
最后一层的信息，
我认为，
这两个，
虽然说那个方法，
完全不一样，
但是呢，
都是,
一起同工的，
想到了，
我需要，
去在layer wise,。
去进行，
那个,
信息流的，
这样一个改进，
那这两种方法的，
区别,
和它未来的，
上线,
你怎么看，
一个是，
Deep Seek,。
现在在，
在用的MHC，
这是它比较独特的，
一个做法，
然后另一方面是，
也是最近Kimity的，
attention residuals,。
这个,
我认为，
对于我们资源比较有限，
来说,
MHC,
它的实现起来，
infrared,。
相较于attention residual,。
还是,
相对比较简单的，
对于我，
我来说的话，
可能,
就是更加倾向于，
那个,
去搞MHC相关，
就包括我们，
1月份,
提出Deep Delta Learning,。
就是,
类似的hybrid connection,。
技术,
去进行另一方面的，
那个,
规划处理，
在只增加，
至上,
就是说，
达到了非常好的，
那个performance,。
attention residuals的话,。
它就是，
它对infrared的要求，
更高,
对,
但是呢，
因为它对于，
层一层之间，
关系,
一个更加精确的，
这样一个描述，
所以说，
我认为，
它的上限，
会比hybrid connection,。
这一系列，
研究它的上限，
会更高，
MHC这个事儿，
因为它可能，
也是在训练，
这个过程的，
它对你们，
比如说，
推理框架去做，
一些,
变化,
会有影响吗？
其实,
是很多的，
就是,
从推理的，
来说,
MHC,
把残差的简单，
AR的变成一个，
需要这个，
sync hold,。
归易化的，
然后,
还要给gim，
加一个mixing，
这个操作，
会复杂许多，
然后呢，
这个,
我们,
当然直接挑战，
是,
先前的算子，
对于这个，
MHC,
而言,
是不够高小的，
cernal,
包括,
我们最近也released了，
用titan,
去给mhc,
写的sblytkcernal,。
ok,
这个东西在小batch，
解码情况下，
能够显著，
提高gpu的利用率，
我们不太需要，
在乎这个，
具体的cernal是什么东西，
但是,
为了新的算法，
定制新的cernal的事情，
在v3以前，
其实做的，
没有那么的频繁，
然后这个时代，
我们也做的，
越来越多，
不过,
可以,
透过比较新写的，
是现在我们也有了，
对于titan,。
能够,
更高射的是，
支持这个，
为新算法，
写cernal吧。
ok，那到现在，
其实我们是，
谈点了，
就是你说的那四个，
一起来的，
新东西里面的，
前三个，
有新的注意力机制，
有那个优化器，
没有,
它没有一些改进，
然后还有mhc，
就是dpc,
比较独特的做法，
然后第四个就是，
它在infra上，
的两个关键词，
Town和fp4,。
这个可以称扬，
你主要展开说一说吧，
你这个应该比较了解。
这两个词，
Again,
这个,
都是付出了无数，
infra工程师的，
心情老多。
ok,简单,
先介绍一下，
tile,
我喜欢叫做这个，
叫titan,
因为titan,。
听得像是那种，
拳击大师的名字。
ok，这么理解，
就是说，
大家可以想，
就是,
infra解决的问题，
应该叫做，
给定同样的，
计算路径的情况下，
怎么让一个计算更快，
然后写kernel，
大概就是说，
我们底层有，
非常多的这种盒，
就是,
这些盒，
会结合一些硬件特性，
然后,
嗯,
虽然可能，
我们做的，
举证计算，
都是同一块，
但是经过不同的盒，
它拿到效率是不一样的，
举个简单例子，
比如说我给一个，
这个4096 x 4096的,。
举证做一些计算，
你可以把它按照，
128 x 128的差,。
可以把它按照，
250 x 256的差,。
然后不同的硬件，
因为它的这个，
所以有的硬件，
可能喜欢128，
有的硬件可能喜欢256，
总之就是，
嗯,
kernel,
大概就是干了这么一个事，
就是让，
这些底层的举证计算，
变得越来越快，
当然还有很多，
很多不同种的kernel，
然后,
写kernel,。
是依赖于，
很多语言的，
然后这种语言，
我们称之为DSL，
就是,
domain specific language,。
这里面，
我们一般拿这三种，
做个对比嘛，
就是,
苦打,
Titan,
还有TileLang,。
最有名的，
我们一般称之为，
英伟达的互声盒，
英伟达是一家伟大的，
硬件公司，
然后在硬件上，
一层的软件，
就是在苦打这一层，
也是做得非常非常的优秀，
苦打呢，
毫无疑问，
是性能最高，
但是开发维护成本，
也最高的，
一套语言，
然后,
Titan,
极大的这样的，
写kernel的门槛，
虽然还是很高，
它比苦打的门槛，
低了很多，
然后坏住就是，
它确定了很多，
表达能力，
以及它的极端性能，
然后,
可能同一个kernel，
你用titan写出来，
比起用苦打写出来，
苦打就会效率高不少，
然后,
Titan的话,。
走的算是一条中间路线，
就是,
它比titan更底层一起，
然后表达力也更强，
然后又比手写，
苦打的开发效率更高，
然后,
Titan也是这个，
这个国内发展起来，
一个优秀的开源项目，
然后,
在这个V4的报告里面，
绕了太浪的几个优势，
我可以简单解读一下，
就是,
把一些kernel的启动，
开销压缩到了微妙级别，
然后,
以及它，
为这个位级可重现，
给了很多的，
提升,
这个位级可重现，
类似于，
我同样一个，
Proud Shrew给,。
DeepSig V4,。
如果我用太浪的话，
它的,
它,
两次forward推理出来的结果，
可能是更好重现的，
这对于推理工程师去debug，
是很有帮助的，
这些可能科普一下，
就是,
接什么太浪，
Treaton和,。
枯大的区别吧，
然后,
我个人来看的话，
太浪的长期价值，
是为了，
这个是在，
这个新算法，
快速开发高性能，
Kernel这些事情的，
编辑成本，
大大降低了，
这个在DeepSig，
提这个MHC的时候，
他们就写了嘛，
这个,
他们已经为MHC写了一版，
太浪的，
这个,
混合精度的Kernel，
然后,
太浪现在非常流行，
我们团队，
S-Lang这边的话，
也是针对推理场景的。
small batch site decoding,。
做了一个speed K的，
太浪版本，
太浪现在已经被，
前沿的Lab，
当做算法的，
默认选择之机了，
这也是，
可能最近一年半的发生，
你说的这个前沿，
AI Lab是,。
就所有的美国的，
也都算上全球的，
前沿AI Lab,。
嗯,对,
大家对于这块的投入，
其实是很大的，
因为,
很早以前这个，
大家细臣这个做，
做编译系，
这一层，
是非常非常苦的，
但是现在，
大家也看到了，
这层的优势，
这一层的重要性，
嗯,
我觉得这个，
还挺感慨的，
因为这是，
北大,
就杨智老师那边，
他们发起的一个，
开员项目，
但是,
后面肯定也有很多，
社区的人，
一起来贡献和维护啊，
然后他又是，
就你刚说DSL，
这个比较底层的语言，
其实,
在五年前的时候，
那会儿我刚来晚点啊，
有一个采访，
就是去采访，
红萌的负责人，
然后他就提到说，
他们以前在华为，
就做红萌的时候，
他们想去招那种，
就是会编语言的人，
在国内就非常非常难找，
就找不到，
因为他们那个，
做得很早嘛，
就差不多可能，
之前十年前吧，
他们就有在想做这个事情啊，
对，这个，
我可以说，
这个做编语期，
一直是一个，
非常伟扎的事业，
真的非常的苦，
而且他，
并不是一个，
那么容易出名的事情，
因为,
这些人听上去，
他,
嗯，很扎实，
然后,
嗯,
他离商业层面很远，
所以,
他越来越受到关注，
然后,
我前面也提到，
这个,
台湾和，
库达,
然后,
可以这么说，
就是,
严格来说，
我看来，
这个,
台湾和库达是DSL，
库达不是，
库达太全面了，
就以至于他，
不算很specific，
OK,
然后,
台湾和库达做事的抽象，
我个人理解都，
很不错，
所以,
简单来说，
就是,
我觉得，
台湾,
为了表达力，
放弃的，
会是怎么样了？
就是,
他是帮助说，
比如说，
库达这个生态，
更丰富，
更完善了，
还是说，
他也有可能，
和其他的，
国产的芯片，
或者什么其他的芯片，
结合,
他们可以一起来，
和你伟达形成一种竞争，
Hard to say,。
我觉得这是一个，
复杂的关系，
就,
这个类似，
各个模型厂商之间，
彼此会发这个，
技术报告，
然后,
大家可能会彼此学习，
但是,
另一方面，
就是,
Person,
相比库达，
也有类似于，
C++,
相比汇边，
或者说Person，
相比C,
就是,
不同的层级而已，
对,
库达还是要，
更底层一些，对吧？
对,
就是库达，
他直接就是，
跟那个，
硬件进行交互，
那像Telon的话，
他可以用在，
就是,
别的芯片的，
厂商,
做了这层，
更底层的软件上吗？
事实上，
也是如此，
很多硬件厂商，
也会主动去，
支持这些DSL，
就是,
推特中国，
这个生态权益，
是有非常非常多的，
硬件厂商，
一块,
HOST起来的，
你们怎么看，
就是,
Deep Sake,。
用了非常多的Telon，
当然,
你也说到这个，
是一个，
全球的Lib，
也都在做的事情，
然后,
可以说，
他们在这个上面，
投入的，
是额外的，
要多一些吗？
因为我看，
V3.2,
的一些就提到了，
我觉得这个，
就是,
我只能说，
他的投入了很多，
披露出来的，
内部技术实现，
是相对有限的。
嗯，这是一个，
关键词，
然后一方面，
另一个关键词，
你前面提到，
你说是FP4，
我们其实，
先前提到过这个，
Deep Sake,。
V3,
是第一个把FP8，
这个,
做到一个，
很大量级的工作，
到了V4,
你把FP4,
给做出来的，
我想像，
难道在往下，
怎么会，
继续,
更激烈的，
有更激烈的压缩吗？
非常值得期待，
然后,
我们可以对比，
只看最后一位嘛，
4816,
就是,
它代表的是这个，
浮点数的储存位宽，
比如说BF16，
就是用16位来储存，
一个浮点数嘛，
然后FP4,
就是,
同样的一个数字，
我只用4位数来表达，
然后,
呃,
之外来说，
这些,
迪大,
最大的区别，
就是,
数位在不但被减半，
好说是，
我们的风值算力，
肯定会，
得到很大的环解，
然后,
除此之外，
给我们的显存容量，
这个提升，
呃,
无理想见，就是，
当然,
今天提算力算力算力，
其实,
还有两个很关键的词，
显存容量和数据多起太宽，
也是大模型训练的，
一个显著瓶颈，
FP8的精度，
加速到FP4，
这个,
显然,
显存和带宽需求，
近似于是砍斑了的，
这个,
是可以带来很明显的提速，
以前,
业界是很少有人，
在超大规模训练中，
直接使用FP4的，
首先,
范围时代是非常的狭窄，
很容易在训练过程当中，
出现T度溢出或者规律，
所以,
呃,
这个DeepSig,。
为了解决，
FP4的这个训练，
无论是pre-training,。
还是post-training都用了，
非常多的，
工程上的巧思，
然后这个，
我可以pick一个比较，
我自己最熟练的这个，
东西叫做QAT，
就是他们在就post-training的时候，
做了所谓的量化，
感知训练，
Quantization-aware-training,。
它是一种叫做，
训练时模拟量化，
采样时真实量化的一种方案，
呃,
我们可以理解，
这个强化水晶，
是一个两阶段的循环，
一个阶段是采样，
就是,
模型拿到了这个，
系统机的，
这个输入，
然后开始，
生成这个回复，
然后进行采样，
然后,
之后采样子得到的东西，
进行打分，
然后再把这些打分拿去训练，
所以,
它就分为了，
一个采样阶段和训练阶段，
采样阶段，
这是我们生出的Rollout，
然后,
呃,
我们可以到这来讲，
在训练阶段的话，
我们会做一个叫，
模拟量化的操作，
训练时，
我们在优化系，
维持FP32的主权重，
然后在计算前，
先将其压缩到FP4的范围，
然后在，
无所谓反量化，
回到FP8进行计算，
这段就是，
我们说的伪量化，
它进行了一步快速的，
快速的量化，
再反量化回来，
这过程其实，
中间没有进行任何的，
前向计算，
它只是，
就做这么一个，
Flipping的操作，
能够得到体现，
做了这一步，
这个伪量化之后，
我们再用Blockwise，
the scale,。
the scale point,。
去把力讯点给兜出，
这样模型，
虽然没有在，
训练阶段，
这个真正的，
受到量化影响，
但是它已经适应了，
这个低精度的损失，
然后回到这个采样阶段，
我们会进行，
真实的FP4量化，
到了这一步，
我们会把，
前面那个，
量化得到FP4的权重，
拿去真正的去做采样，
然后,
这样,
到了采样阶段FP4的权重，
让这个物理提速，
得到真正的实现，
然后,
更值得欣喜的是，
推理阶段的FP4的，
这种采样，
和我们之后的，
模型部署是一致的，
因为,
看现在DPC的发布的，
那个Trackpoint,。
它也是FP4的嘛，
所以说，
训练过程中，
拿去采样的那个权重，
就是拿来发布的权重，
它比如说，
我们拿FP8，
训练好了之后，
得到一个FP8的权重，
再把它量化成FP4，
这样其实，
还是会有进度损失的，
所以,
通过这种，
训练端度伪量化，
然后采样时的，
真实量化的方案，
其实,
这个,
强化学习的效率，
得到很大的提升，
然后,
呃,
我们可以举一个，
更有意思的例子，
就是，强化学习，
经常我们会认为，
它在,
越大的模型和，
越长的，
越长的这个Token，
Budget的下面，
采样是越重的，
采样可能会占到，
百分之七十以上的世界，
然后在采样的时候，
我们把，
未宽和显存，
读取,
压力大大降低，
采样速度有很好的提升，
呃，这个，
做得非常的具体，
总之,
我就quity away,。
就是,
这套这个伪量，
这套训练时伪量化，
然后,
采样时真实量化的方案，
在Deep Sake的诺文当中，
也有很强的体现，
所以,
这个作为英法同行，
这个,
可能是我们去年，
在十月份左右的，
一个重点，
然后,
先前Kimi的K-2，
其实,
也有用这套方案，
我们S-Down的R-1团队，
去年就肯这块硬骨头，
我们做了两个工作，
一个叫做，
FP-8的全流程，
强化学习，
就是,
训练的时候用FP-8，
然后,
推理时候用FP-8，
还有一个是，
Int-4的quity,。
Int-4和FP-4,。
其实不太一样，
但是,
可以想在，
其实,
也是一些，
比较激进的压缩方案，
然后,
呃,
基本上，
这个行业里面，
大家还是躺过同一条河的，
这个背后的肩心，
是很,
是难闷可贵的，
OK,
然后,
这个量化，
RL,
做的还是很理先，
不过我们，
其实相比，
DeepSig,。
还是有一些这个，
差距,
我们的，
Int-4的这个，
量化感知训练，
在采样，
还是做的W4A16，
就是说，
这个,
呃,
全众是这个4位，
但是,
几乎只是16位，
然后,
DeepSig,。
做到更极限的W4A4，
就是,
所谓的全众是，
4位款,
但是,
几乎只是，
8位款,
然后,
继续弓箭靠南的方向，
我有一个问题是，
如果,
DeepSig,。
他自己把，
推理框架给开源了，
他和别的，
就官方的推理框架开源了，
开源的这种，
框架的关系，
或者是什么，
OK,
这个,
其实是一个开源，
就是,
其实是开源推理框架，
和避源推理框架的，
一些,
手楼学上的区别，
我觉得，
开源推理框架的一个，
重点是，
重口要调，
比如说，
我们同样一套框架，
领先,
我们要surf DeepSig,。
然后,
可能有小米的模型，
minimax的模型，
kimi的模型，
我们要在，
这么多模型中间，
都要支持上，
这种,
就是,
整合性，
是非常非常重要的，
这可能是，
我觉得，
开源的推理引擎，
和DeepSig,。
类似推理引擎的，
重大区别，
那这一步来说，
就作为一个，
这种开源的，
要支持很多模型的，
这个框架，
它最后给，
开发者，
或者说给你们，
都要用户的，
这个价值是，
这个推理引擎，
对于很多，
这个公司，
是有直接需求的，
开源推理引擎，
技能提升，
也会反过来，
铺石就是，
是必原的推理引擎，
训练上，
其实也是一样的，
就是,
开源很多时候，
未必能做的，
比必原领先，
然后,
我觉得推理上面，
必原和开源，
其实,
差距并不大，
但是训练上面，
其实,
必原的训练，
会比开源，
还是要领先不少的，
我说,
开源有个很大的意义，
也是,
我们的训练引擎，
是比开源的训练，
强大很多，
然后,
以前REO,
也是一个负担，
非常非常重的事情，
比如说，
一个模型可能，
二月份上线，
可能到了五六月份，
才会有开源的，
REO框架,
能够把它的REO跑起来，
这点上来说，
我也比较信心，
这个我们团队，
这次,
其实也做到了一个，
在发布当天，
就支持这个REO的，
全联录，
就是,
逻辑上来说，
这个REO和推理，
是很相关的，
这是推理，
是做这个，
不带,
参数回传的，
我们做强大学，
就care,
采样完了，
再做参数回传，
我还是觉得，
非常高兴，
能够在如此，
巨大的MOE模型上面，
同时做好推理，
同时做好REO，
然后我们在，
训练策和推理策的，
一致性，
也做到了极致，
我也可以预见，
FP4,
已经像是，
正式走出了，
这个硬件厂商的PPT，
从这个开源，
语言模型世界里面，
真正跑上，
那像FP4的，
目前来说，
是不是，
这么大模型上，
GODBC可用了，
就开源的，
可以看到，
技术,
细节的模型里面，
其实这个，
那个GPTOSS,。
其实也是，
但是大家的，
这个技术审则，
不完整一致，
总的说，
FP4,
是一个，
全世界一起努力的方向，
但至于说，
避免模型是怎样的，
外界就不太清楚了，
什么,
另外一个，
用的FP4,
是因为打，
因为它自己，
黄人群想推这个吧，
对他们推动的方向之一，
然后BLACKWELL卡,。
也是支持这个FP4，
对，然后前面就是，
讲了这四个，
四个这个新的东西嘛，
然后在这个报告的最后一部分，
其实他们自己是，
讲了训练的过程，
包括预训的过程，
包括后训练和测评，
这个部分，
你们有看到什么，
觉得比较有意思的亮点吗？
一个比较亮点，
就是那个，
它的poach训练的里面，
就相当于是，
先分裂专家，
然后就像它是，
再进行那个，
Unpolicy distillation,。
最近一段时间，
就是Unpolicy distillation,。
又开始，
大家都在研究这个东西，
但是呢，具体怎么做，
其实各家还是有，
很大区别的，
征流这个做法，
在Deep Seek V3和R1上,。
它其实有一点时间，
只如果它是把强的模型，
征流到比较小的模型，
比如像，
那个R1征流出来的，
千万模型上，
当然V4的就征流了，
就相当于是，
它先训练一些，
小的专家，
然后把这些小的专家的，
学习了技能，
征流起来，
就是节省它的参数量，
就像那些是，
就是在训练过程中，
专家越多，
它容量越大了，
但是呢，
那个专家越多，
它的那个显存呢，
就是它的参数量，
它的要求也比较大，
我们先让这些专家先学好，
然后再把这些专家的一些精华，
给它提示出来，
能够显著的提高，
最终的模型的能力。
这个一封其实，
讲的这个很有意思，
就是他们做的这个，
叫多专家训练，
这个,
本上这个是要解决，
所谓的多目标优化问题，
可以想象在这个九川说，
这个同时优化的目标的个数，
同时优化目标个数的多少，
是致力上限的体现，
一个人能够同时操控的系统，
它的参数越大，
致力它的能力越强，
像刚才一封讲，
这个联合训练，
就像是在一个，
多目标的这个，
我们Century Loose Surface 里面,。
找一个Pullover to U,。
但是实际的工程里面，
这个最优点是很难，
同时是找到了，
因为,
这个T度的走向很复杂，
这个冲突很严重，
所以说，
像刚才一封提到的嘛，
就是,
如果你，
一味的是Push Coding 的能力，
可能你的数学就不好了，
你把数学修好了，
你可能这个，
对指令的遵循又不好了，
所以现在的做法，
其实是，
所谓的先分立在真流嘛，
就是在各个目标上，
都是找找局部的最优质，
让我们再让一个统一的学生模型，
去同时你和多个这个，
教室模型的数据分布，
有点像是我们学高速的时候，
教数学实验有这么刻，
讲过一个叫差值的东西，
我们把一个在复杂的，
这个Loose Service 上面的，
联合优化问题，
换是一个在已经收敛的，
一些离散点之间做差值，
这个事情在工程上面，
听上去是一个，
更稳定可控的事情，
然后,
先前来说，
这个在业界，
我们也有过很多类似的尝试嘛，
就是说，
这个早年领先的某开源模型，
也有过这个，
所谓的专家聚合阶段，
然后,
他们的公开细节比较少，
然后困的话，
自己觉得都是开源领域的原神啊，
这个困的Pulse Training 阶段，
就说过他们有这个Multi-Stage 的这个，
专家聚合阶段，
然后,
学术阶段，
一直都有这个，
所谓的模型聚合，
还有模型的这个，
叫做模型Spawn 这种技术，
我觉得，
大概是从有GDP2 的时候，
就有人在做这些事情，
硅谷这边的话，
前年的必然模型，
我认为大规律也会有相同的思路，
但是,
因为商业原因，
大量的披露很有限，
然后开源这个生态，
使这一波中国实验室，
给整个AR 领域的实质贡献。
嗯,
测评的部分，
其实我们前面聊过了，
你们有什么还要补充的吗？
这个,
我经常做一些 really 的拼行，
有句话就这么讲了，
这个,
我本格毕业的时候，
有位OP 领域，
非常知名的研究者，
给我说过一件事，
他觉得，
我们不能去优化，
我们不能评测的东西，
如果我们不能给我们，
想要优化的能力，
一个分数，
我们根本就不知道，
我们的优化对不对？
We cannot optimize what we cannot,。
what we cannot evaluate.。
所以,
经常大家会讲一个词，
Bunchmark,。
也会讲个词叫 evaluation，
我其实觉得，
我们最好把这东西，
叫做 evaluation,。
而不是 bunchmark,。
因为 bunchmark 指的是，
一个个具体的任务，
但是 bunchmark 实际上会过时的，
可能一个 bunchmark 可能发布一年两年，
它就 saturated 了,。
所以大家都说，
它是 a finishing problem,。
但是 evaluation 这个事情，
永远都是存在，
而且它是一个非常，
一直都是一个非常重要的事情，
我最近有一个很大的感觉，
evaluation 越来越难做，
因为我们的场景越来越复杂，
这个具体的意思，
经常 cloud code 更新了之后，
就会有人去批评说，
这个版本怎么更新了，
然后某某方面变差了，
我是非常的好奇，
对于 cloud code 这样的工具，
大家是怎么去评估，
一个 future 要不要更新的，
这个例子就是，
我们作为政治的这个行业，
大家有万千种想法，
然后每一个算法，
听着都有那么一些道理，
但是直观上来讲，
你是不可能把所有的，
所有的想法都做了，
然后你说这个东西就再变好，
对，你加了东西越多，
可能这个东西就再变差，
有个词叫做 less is more，
你这个东西加进去，
真的有没有变好，
这个东西是需要量化来说明的，
所以 evaluation 就是做这个量化，
它尽量的拼开屏感觉走，
否则我们的优化就会出问题，
所以 take back,。
就是,
我觉得这一版 deep-seq 的这个。
bridge market 一如既往做得很扎实，
而且我从来坚定的认为，
我们要做好evaluation，
而且evaluation 只能做到。
越来越好才行，
否则我们这个行业。
会变成一种，
这个早些年修炼气功的感觉，
我们会觉得这些气功大师，
让人觉得非常的费劫，
因为,
从我们的科学教育观来讲，
这个东西，
有没有什么客观的标准说，
它这些奇怪的功，
真的能够给社会带来。
正向的正义，
还是说它只是挑出几个地址说，
这个人的并好了，
对，我就现在就是，
不做好evaluation,。
我们这个行业就会陷入这种，
这个自信气人的恶性循环，
这点上来看的话，
deep-seq这次的这个evaluation,。
他们测了什么呢，
多不认为的稳定性，
长沉对话，人格一致，
还有什么工具将用的鲁棒性，
这些可能在v4的报告里面提到了，
而且我觉得这也是v4能不能进入。
第一梯队的真正问题所在，
OK,
所以crate takeaway 就是,。
benchmarking会过时,。
然后任何一个benchmark都要被发满了那一天，
那是evaluation一直要是一个公正的追求，
否则我们这个行业是没法，
去盖的整个领域，
积极向上发展，
对，我觉得这事儿是确实越来越难了，
包括最近Ops 4.2期更新之后，
就很多人认为还是要用4.6，
确实也是，
现在有个词叫做vive checking，
或者vive benchmarking,。
就是说，
我已经感觉不出来模型的好坏了，
跟着他我的有限期的对话说，
你想这个任务4.5能做，
为什么你4.7就做不好，
我们已经进入了benchmark的可信危机，
这模型乍一看，
这benchmark全都是90家，
但是实际差异大概都说很大，
所以说，
我觉得这个generation的agency evaluation。
还没有达成共识，
我们还需要更好的evaluation基金，
逸峰你有什么要补充的吗？
我觉得就是benchmark，
就相当于是在某一个具体任务上，
得到一个能力，
但是我认为的话，
更重要的还是，
去发现和提出新的ability domain，
比如说agentic的能力，
比如像那个长生注意力的能力，
dermain比具体的某个benchmark，
重要程度更高，
因为就是人家一旦提出这个benchmark的话，
我觉得，
就是双满，
也就是半年到一年的时间，
Vis在这方面，
应该也没有提什么新的领域的能力，
对吧,
这个是没有提的，
是的,
所以说就是，
我觉得就是说，
还是不是那么特别，
连阵营的一点之一吗？
我觉得一个非常有意思的点是，
我们发现这几代模型，
它居然没有做degradation，
就是先前好过的任务，
它再也没有插下去过，
今年上其实还是很值得心喜的，
当然我觉得可能一方面的，
另一个代价就是，
现在模型的context lens，
到底有什么力量发掘的地步？
OK,
我想起来这个讲，
benchmark里面,。
他们提到那个多轮的这个，
多轮工具调用，
我们去年就是Deepseq v3发的时候，
当时我自己有篇paper，
我们当时也是去年头likelier，
前几天你敢，
也在巴西开会，
但我没有去，
这是也是讲这个，
评估一个语言模型，
在github上面，
去面对雕砖的reviewer，
去交一个pr，
然后把它merge这个能力，
这个其实，
它相对于以前叫什么打数学竞赛，
还有这个解决，
比如说修一个单册，
像sweeper这种修单册，
还是区别很大的，
这个可能跟现在的call code，
ideal很像,。
这call code,。
比如说你让它去完成一个工程，
你要交付的时候，
你得希望把它merge进去，
对吧,
然后在merge之前，
你还得和你的reviewer。
做很多能力battle，
所以我，
感受中就是，
至少我自己做过benchmark来说，
我很欣喜，
我们做的benchmark，
能够得到更多的认证，
而且即便今年，
这个benchmark,。
它已经被刷满了，
无所谓，
至少首先这个actlier，
这个我们拿到很好的分数，
它这边all the paper,。
然后另一个方面，
我是非常欣喜，
见到,
这几年，
这个能力就能被刷满，
那我们明年，
是不是可以期待一些，
更劲爆的东西，
ok,
最近我自己，
比较关注的benchmark，
叫做cloudbench,。
就是,
就这个名字，
就是opencloud cloudbench,。
它就是评估在这个opencloud，
这种应用场景，
下面用户的，
满意都是什么样子，
我觉得这，
我,
我也比较希望，
到了明年，
这种类似的benchmark，
这种,
个人非严肃，
编程助手的benchmark，
也能被刷满，
那我们，
肯定会有新的挑战，
新的,
全新的应用人能到来，
对,
接下来，
正好我们可以讨论一下，
就是,
行业正在发生的一些，
更广泛的变化，
因为最近的模型更新，
还是非常密集的，
那从3月底到现在，
呃,
包括前面提到的，
小米的，
minimo 2.5,。
glm 5.1,。
minimax 2.7,。
k226,
obs4.7,
gbt 5.5,。
你们觉得这些，
所有的模型里面，
可以总结出，
大家有哪些，
在努力的，
共性的方向，
对于模型来说的话，
它的方法，
和architecture,。
实际上，
还是在某种程度上，
去统的，
就是,
它机座，
也就是ma，
但是它会对一些，
很多,
其他的architecture的feature,。
但是机座，
基本上，
就像是，
继续在它的架构，
去进行，
拓展,
对,
然后包括，
像优化器，
大家都，
都在用mu，
然后之前的话，
可能,
就是admw,
甚至,
还会有一些，
那个,
就是mu,
优化器，
或者说，
那个,
就像在mu，
优化器的技术上，
去进行微调，
那个agent的能力，
我觉得，
是那个，
这一波，
就是所有，
不管是，
开源模型，
还是bm模型，
都在,
注重的趋势，
因为,
就是,
像openclaw,。
clawcode,。
这些,
就是,
让大家去发现的，
模型研究，
它未来上面画，
可能方向，
给这些，
那个agent,。
在微调之前的，
会员服务以你。
这个,
其实是一个很，
有利的商业问题，
就是,
你说要把它，
做成一个订阅值，
还是要做成一个token by token的，
一个机费，
我就现在，
其实我心里是，
vote for 订阅值,。
我就订阅值，
是一个更好的商业模式，
然后你完全可以，
先订阅，
订阅满楼的招，
再让大家，
交token的钱，
但是,
实际上，
大部分的用户，
不会用到，
订阅的顶格，
所以,
做订阅值，
拋却订阅值，
转而是，
按token 机费，
可能订阅值也扛不住，
这如果说，
订阅值它高了，
没有用户满，
订阅值低了的话，
其实公司，
公司是亏的。
嗯,
这,
这是一个，
统一的商业问题，
然后,
我不觉得，
现在哪家公司，
有给说一个，
很好的结论，
是哪家，
这个我们看，
呃,
可以吧，
就是,
我觉得，
coco 的这么，
成功的商业产品，
究竟,
盈利如何，
现在呢，
看到财务数据，
现在很多那种，
做视频深沉的产品，
就是偏 AIGC 应用的这些产品，
比较类似于陈阳，
说的两种结合，
然后如果你用完，
用满这个额度之后，
你就要额外买几分，
然后,
影视从业者，
就因为他们有刚去去用这个东西，
他们还是比较接受的，
所以,
所以视频深沉类的产品，
的课单价还真的挺高的，
就比我想象中高很多，
我其实在商业上面，
非常的，
喜欢他们视频，
这样的一个生态，
但是坏消息是，
视频深沉模型的开，
开源的视频深沉模型，
和必然的差距，
确实很大，
因为我发现，
好像没有什么人，
愿意开源视频深沉模型，
有可能，
这正式说明了，
他还真的挺赚钱吧，
好像,
就到目前为止，
呃,
就,
就已经开源的，
然后,
大家认为比较先进的一个，
应该也是，
称问,
呃,是,
阿里那边开源的，
就同一万项，
嗯,
我最近做，
这个语音模型，
也做的比较多，
就是我们做，
这个语音深沉的模型嘛，
然后,
可以想象，
就比如说，
现在开源的语音深沉模型，
相比,
比如说，
JAMINI,
相比OPENLINE的，
GDP4O那个时代的模型，
还是有不少差距的，
我的一个亏论，
就是,
这些模型，
应该很赚钱，
就是,
还有一个，
就是说，
视频模型，
它的用户年纪，
特别大，
相比语音模型，
难说,
所以就是说，
视频模型，
我的感觉，
就是关注度和舆论，
是全部被coding，
被通用的这种agent，
吸引走的，
因为这方面的竞争，
非常焦着，
而是都是最大的公司在竞争，
但另一方面，
确实可能视频是一个，
跟创业友好，
或者说，
AIGC这个方向，
是个跟创业友好的方向，
包括语音啊，
像Eleven Labs这种公司，
对吧,
在好像在一个，
相对自己的空间里，
在存在这种，
这是相同的部分，
那你们观察到，
各家的差异是什么了，
包括中美之间，
会有什么，
这种分化的趋势吗？
首先,
我们可以讨论一下，
国内的比较有代表性的，
这几家开源模型，
然后,
我觉得开源里面，
Deepsea和Kinney的,。
这个取向比较接近，
他们做的工程，
和这个创新性，
比较极限吧，
大的MOE,
低的激活，
长下下下温，
还有一些aggressive的cost，
然后千万，
还有Minmax,。
我觉得在RU训练端，
然后在长上下温，
落地方面，
都有非常扎实的机类，
大家的发力点，
不太一样，
Deepsea我觉得，
这五家公司，
人就非常的有希望，
所以,
这里可能，
漏掉了小米，
然后,
小米,
大家可以看到，
昨天这个模型，
V1.5的pro,。
然后,
在Arena上面的分数，
也是比V4要高的，
Kinney这时代，
非常激烈，
看到这种，
百花齐放的局面，
我,
至少还是非常开心的，
但是坏处就是，
这些开源的模型，
也给了，
也给了我们开源，
推的引擎，
也有很多的，
就是我们的工作量，
很大,
而且我们没有提到，
接月和浑源。
To myself,。
就是,
接月的话，
在这个多摩泰上面，
其实他们发力，
是很早的，
然后,
我是觉得，
现在多摩泰，
是一个发霜下水的，
一个状态，
所以就像，
刚才,
刚才易峰也提到了，
这个,
多摩泰要不要做，
原生多摩泰，
这些事情，
是非常值得研究的，
然后,
浑源的话，
这个,
最近,
这个姚顺宇，
这个我和易峰的学长，
他这个回去，
掌帅浑源，
他不是在这个，
一个T的以上，
这个模型的排桌上面，
但是在300b这个规模，
我觉得，
做的也非常的扎实，
现在是3.0的preview，
对,
如果走到3.0，
他可能上了pro，
他可能又进了微信端，
那这个格局，
会很有意思，
这我觉得，
也不久之后，
应该可能就会看到，
美国模型，
就是总体来说，
就是,
他更多追求，
就是我开启了一个新的领域，
比如像我，
长江洋文，
那个见面来，
就是谷歌团队，
提出了，
然后多摩泰融合，
那个agent能力，
他的性能，
跨时代的提高，
就像最近，
很火的那个，
那个1米几2，
就像他比，
之前的模型，
有的就是，
跨时代的提高，
还有点就是，
中国模型，
他更加，
测试于性价比，
美国模型，
就是大家都知道，
非常贵，
那中国模型，
就是说，
是在同样的能力下，
收费比美国模型，
小一个数量级，
我觉得，
这跟中国，
充足的技术人员，
储备,
所以有很大关系，
倩阳,
你有什么要补充的吗？
你观察到的，
中美,
模型,
进化的这种差别？
我在美国的话，
我之前在amazon的，
这部agiceflab工作室，
我也和一封都在，
C的有过，
14,
这个generation long horizon agent,。
只有一个词，
精叹,
包括open cloud,。
包括这个cloud code，
这两个产品，
我觉得心里是很admired，
cloud的这一代模型，
4.5之后,
在多能agentic coding上面的表现，
相比于，
这个先前真的进步了，
非常非常多，
可以想象这个rlhf，
或者rlenf,。
这一套，
我们先前来了的方法论，
设了几年积累之后，
加上,
剧量的，
高质量人类反馈数据，
已经在，
美国这边，
形成了一个，
非常强大的数据壁环，
中国团队这边的话，
我觉得强项，
是这个架构，
创新的密度，
还有令人，
泽舌的工程完成度，
v4一个报告里面，
混合吸收注意力，
MSC MIUI,V4,。
台湾,
这么多事情，
全部都换掉，
并且跑通，
这种决心和执行力，
是相当罕见的，
我觉得，
这个中美的路径，
风格上有所不同，
但整个行业，
还是在，
徘徊上升的，
美国的模型，
没有做的那么吸收，
就大没有在追求这个，
你觉得这不是个选择的问题，
是实现的问题，
对,
而且就是，
美国这边，
算力比较多嘛，
对,
它不需要做那么吸收，
因为吸收它，
它会牺牲一定上限，
就大家的选择，
我就是去充性能的，
反正我这么贵，
也有人买，
我就先做到那些，
之前模型，
可能做不到的事，
然后我再想，
降成本的问题，
是的,
因为理论上，
你性能，
能充上去之后，
就降成本这个事，
我觉得，
它会相对确定一点，
当然,
你也是要，
更多资源，
很支持，
它说的有G，
对,
就是,
可能很多人批评，
说这个中美，
现在是这个，
大搞太空近战，
只有中美能搞太空近，
没有任何国家，
能够,
玩得此这一波，
得业比赛，
你们觉得，
就是,
再过一两年来看的话，
V4最可能被记住的是，
什么成果，
或者说，
是它的，
什么思路，
和想法，
可能,
为数不多，
能被记住，
所以就是token wise，
的这种，
极致压缩，
从算法上面来说，
对,
因为之前的话，
大家就是，
可能KV开始，
更多人使，
就现在是，
单个token里面，
像围压之类的，
比上MMA,
就是先降围在身围，
对，都是设计了，
单个token的，
这种压缩，
然后token wise的,。
压缩的话，
应该是V4，
首先被，
应用到，
这种工业级别的模型上，
对,
然后其他的话，
就是,
算法上面，
就是没有什么特别，
就是说，
是让我，
非常惊艳的地方。
我和一方的观点，
是标类4，
就是,
长上下轮，
极致低接火，
比例,
然后还有一个，
低单token成本，
这个,
组合,
无论是，
这个 architecture wise,。
还是在这个infra wise，
可能都是V4，
留下的持久遗产，
然后,
具体的某一个技术，
比如说MHC，
或者很多注意力，
会不会按照现在的形式，
被采用下去，
可能都像MMA一样，
那是,
可能是那个阶段的最优节，
但是可能过了，
一两个，
一两个round，
它可能会，
被更优险的方案替代，
但是硬件，
可能会反过来推动，
往上这些替代了。
我觉得，
DPSig V4,。
它率先验证了，
成为后世许多，
开源大模型的默认系列。
在这个意义上面，
DPSig,
一直是开源模型的，
参考基地。
然后,
最后一个问题，
就是想问一下，
两位,
接下来的一些，
行动啊，
比如说，
你们选择的一些研究方向，
然后,
或者是，
陈阳,
这边,
因为你已经创业了嘛，
你肯定有，
很多具体的事，
得干的，
有哪些，
可能是，
因为,
比如说V4，
对我来说的话，
就是,
因为我现在，
也没在公司实习，
如果说，
有机会去公司实习，
我可能会，
比较,
想做CSA,
HSA,
这种token-wise的,。
压缩,
这种长文本，
但在,
实验室里面的话，
长文本是很难，
实验的，
所以说，
对我来说，
更倾向于，
就是,
去进一步，
去研究，
那个,
hyper-connection,。
相关的研究，
包括像，
Kimi的attention recital,。
这种,
另一步，
就是说，
就是,
之前是从那个，
ResNet,
到DenseNet,。
这样一步，
我觉得的话，
就是说，
对于Transformer来说，
它可能也是，
会有一个，
相同的这样一个趋势，
就是,
提高层于层之间的，
信息流动，
对,
然后的话，
我自己也在做优化器，
就是说，
那个DeepSeq,。
V4,
它采用的，
就是,
不同的超团数，
那么,
没有问，
它自己，
还能不能，
和去设定，
要到底，
那个,
就是,
Kair Jordan,。
提出了，
五步扭动数字更好，
还是,
那个DeepSeq,。
V4,
采用的，
十步扭动数字更好，
这个还是，
非常值得去，
进一步的探索。
然后,
我的话，
就算,
就算我刚才提到了，
我们有一个，
我今年，
我在,
我在大概去年，
这个时候的，
一个工作，
讲那个，
多轮的A准的，
去给,
去教PR这个事情，
呃,
这算是我之前的一个，
Result方向,。
就是,
研究这种，
Coding下面的，
这种,
真实上，
就像Coding表现嘛，
我可能，
最近不需要做一个Result，
但是我稍微，
稍微用起来，
因为,
现在我，
自己维护，
开源的工具，
会有很多人，
教AI生成的这个PR，
那我有没有什么，
Golden Standard,。
能够,
内化到，
我自己的工作里面来，
我看到什么PR，
我知道这玩意靠谱，
实际上，
我自己出来，
到我的工作那边来，
然后还有一点是，
我最近做这个，
语音模型，
做的比较多，
语音模型上面，
其实,
它的工程优化，
相比语言模型，
差了非常多，
然后包括很多事情，
其实,
可以在语音模型上面，
重现一次，
我觉得，
都是可行的，
这个版本的DeepSig的话，
还是做到了，
很优秀的这个，
PD分离,
还有这个MTP，
这些工作，
我会认为，
PD分离,
可能未必要在，
语音模型上实现，
但是MTP对语音，
就像是，
现在可能，
你打开手机，
跟豆包对话，
你会觉得，
豆包,
吐出第一个语音的速度，
还是很快的，
很遗憾在开编上面，
我们做的没有这么优秀，
所以,
我觉得，
这里还是有很大的gap，
我们可以去努力的。
嗯,
OK,
那今天，
非常感谢两位，
做可玩店聊，
分享了，
你们在看到DeepSig V4，
发布之后，
包括最近，
这么密集的，
这么多模型，
更新之后，
观察到的，
一些变化，
尤其是，
展开聊了DeepSig，
这一次，
一下子，
端出来的四个新东西，
然后在1.6T，
这么大的模型上，
都实现了，
就包括，
它新的，
注意力机制，
这个是，
改变了V2-V3的MLA，
主流的做法，
而现在，
Kimi和Gyp的GM,。
还是用的MLA的架构，
然后第二个，
就是,
没有很优化气，
而且DeepSig,。
也在,
之前的，
比较主流的版本上，
做了一些改进，
然后第三个是，
MHC,
一个让训练更，
稳定的方法，
然后最后是，
在Info2层面的，
Tialang还有,。
FP4的,
使用,
那今天的节目就到这里，
各位,
拜拜!
本期节目就到这里，
感谢收听，
如果你对今天聊的话题，
有观察，
好奇或疑问，
欢迎在评论区，
分享想法，
这也会成为，
我们节目的一部分，
让整个讨论更完整，
你也可以把，
我们的节目，
分享给对这个话题，
感兴趣的朋友，
推荐更多，
你想听的，
主题和嘉宾，
你可以从，
podcast等渠道，
关注,
晚点聊，
LateTalk,。
也欢迎关注，
我们的公众号，
晚点LatePost,。
下期再见！